singles day in china is the world's
biggest shopping event
think of black friday cyber monday and
amazon prime day on loop for days
[Music]
and now alibaba the chinese e-commerce
giant that created singles day wants to
use this international platform
aliexpress to help the event go global
from poland
to france
and
brazil alibaba is competing with other
e-commerce platforms like amazon to
capture a larger share of the global
market which is expected to grow by 1.4
trillion dollars by 2025. so to promote
singles day alibaba has hired an army of
influencers around the world i love this
college and beefed up its logistics but
it has to tackle some challenges if it
wants to take a bite off a bigger piece
of the global ecommerce
pie of the first things alibaba is doing
to win over new singles day consumers
abroad
massive sales discounts of up to you
know 50 or even 70
are being offered so it's a very big
event finzy zhang is an e-commerce
analyst based in shanghai who's been
watching alibaba for the past seven
years
so the way it is doing that right now is
basically competing on pricing by
offering cheaper prices
as well as charging less fees
for the merchants when foreign customers
use aliexpress they get direct access to
chinese factories and merchants
the company is also speeding up global
delivery during the international
two-day shopping event this year
it said it's increasing charter flights
from china to cities like seoul and
paris to 100 a week up from 80 flights
alibaba said it also installed 5 000
automated self-pickup lockers across
russia poland spain and france to help
cut delivery costs that would go to
hiring fleets of delivery trucks and
drivers
is one of the 400 influencers alibaba
has hired to promote single stay abroad
in china live streaming is one of the
most popular ways to shop
and senna is doing the same but for a
brazilian audience she says the chinese
company is offering something better
than other shopping platforms
i think the fact that people can see us
we touch the product we have the
feedback of other people that already
purchased the products as well it gives
the audience a very personal
communication but attracting buyers
won't be enough if it wants to compete
with amazon then i think fundamentally
it needs to own more inventory and the
bigger bulk items could become an issue
right now the company lacks the
infrastructure outside china to support
those kinds of sales if we're talking
about a big
air conditioner or refrigerator purchase
shipped from china
i imagine it will be very challenging
the big
home appliance manufacturers they are
not going to you know sell directly in
europe and build a warehouse so it's up
to alibaba if they want to
kind of undertake that
initiative alibaba said it has opened up
its platform to merchants in several
markets already outside of china and
will continue to expand while also
developing warehouses overseas to
improve capacity
it said aliexpress is at the forefront
of its global strategy and according to
brokerage china merchant securities
china's outbound e-commerce market is
expected to grow around 26
every year until 2025.
amazon did not respond to a request for
comment
so john says alibaba should stick to
what they're good at using automated
warehouses innovative ways to live
stream and deliver packages to keep
prices low i think that's where
alibaba's strength lies
it's in its technology and logistics
management if they're able to replicate
that success to europe then maybe they
can you know compete against amazon from
a different angle and you know and
attract more people to ultimately switch
to using alibaba
[Music]